私の知ってる人が、なんていう名前だっけ、変な名前なんだよ、それを。だからこの人って何人だろうと思ってね。
あんまり日本人じゃないって思わないわけ、普通話してれば、ちょっと黒いして、ちょっと見ようと。
あれ? 目とかも本当に日本人のタイプ。 インドネシアってモーズドームいっぱいいるんだよね。
インドネシアってお前ね。インドネシアに俺も行ったからね。
インドネシアでいっぱい、なんだっけ、モーズドーム入って、頭のカバーみたいなのあるじゃん。
マービーの? そうそうそうそう。それいっぱい。
それであの、なんか、別にね、そんなラブレターを書いたもんないんだけど、
でも、なんか、書いちゃった。今度、いつ行くから、ありますね。
だって、お店だから、それ。スーパーマーケットだから。
うんうん。 いつ来るかわかんないって言ってた。
初め、自動車のね、あの、駐車場のテレビみたいなのやってたの。
その人、2人だったかな。 西野。
西野。 普通に、あの、あそこ。
ナショナルとか、自分でいられるんだけど、
メディアとかね、そういうところはちょっとうるさいことがあるんだけど、
いくら買わないと、タダじゃないとか、いろいろなんで、全然認識もちょっとあるんだけど、
結構うるさくて、なんか、自分で、自動車を持ってきてくれたり、いろいろするのよ。
ああ。
そういうのやってる人、お母さんとか、何人とか一緒にやってて、
それが、あの、あの、あの、あの、あの、あの、あの、お母さんとかね、もう、大騒ぎだったんだよ、って言うからね。
えぇーって。
もう、どうするっていうか。
こんなおばあちゃんだからいいじゃない人だから、おばあちゃんなんだから本当に、祈りそれ。
若い人だったら期待やと思うんですけど、それで来かいから行かなくなって、だから今のことを「ここ、おっぱいルシアに行こう」とか言ってたんだよね。
「あ、そうか」。それで「メイメイ、ニシア好きでしょ?」って言ってくれて。好きだったけど。
でも、いろんな面白いものを売っててね。日本のものも売ってるし、いろんな世界でのものを売ってて。
なんかナショナラゾンみたいだよね。
もっとなんか広くていろいろ。